the tallying of kenya's election results
is tense
the last three polls were disputed and
two of them resulted in violence
in many places trades at a standstill
making things even harder for millions
of informal workers already struggling
because of soaring food and fuel prices
there is no business right now because
most of our customers are holding back
and waiting for the results
floaters seem decreasingly convinced by
politicians promises to relieve economic
woes
turnout was about 65 percent compared to
nearly 80 percent in the last election
five years ago
in that poll the electronic voting
system was criticized for being opaque
the supreme court ruled there were
irregularities in its transmission of
data
it annulled the election and ordered a
rerun this time the results forms from
every polling station were made
available online from the moment that
they were transmitted electronically to
here the tally center in nairobi and
while the hard copies are being brought
here anyone can download the images
print them off and tally up the results
rights groups hope that means it'll be
harder to rig the election and easier to
prove any rigging in court
for the first time political parties
have been allowed to run their own tally
centers this one's run by the coalition
of deputy president william ruto who's
one of the two main contenders because
we had a dog in this fight we've already
done our collection and we have our
figures we know how far it has gotten
it's just that we cannot do the
declaration it's at management level to
to compare the two
some media companies are running tally
centers too like this one depending on
which constituencies they count first
some show a lead for ruto and others for
his main opponent former prime minister
ryla rodinga
rights groups say they're worried about
a flurry of false claims of victory and
misinformation on social media
out on the streets supporters of both
ryla and ruto are convinced their
candidate is about to win
now because we are seeing the percentage
is showing that raila bolodinga is
already winning let us wait for the last
one
everyone's waiting to find out who will
be declared the winner and if the
candidates and their supporters will
accept the results
malcolm webb al jazeera nairobi kenya